[Musique]
ce n'est pas un homme découragés qui
s'adresse à vous toutes et à vous tous
bien au contraire c'est un homme résolu
à défendre les libertés vos libertés à
soutenir la vérité et à mobiliser vos
énergies
il est inadmissible que la liberté de
réunion soit dans notre pays
[Musique]
perturbé par des minorités violents
comme ce fut le cas cette nuit à
toulouse où celui qui vous parle a dû
affronter dans le vacarme et sous la
pression de menaces physiques plus de
1000 gauchistes encadrés par de
véritables professionnels de la
subversion casqués armés de chaînes et
de barres de fer
il est inadmissible que la vérité de
l'information ne soit pas complète et
qu'une certaine presse aux ordres de
jeunes c'est qu'ils seront exposé
simplement quelques parcelles des
réunions que j'ai tenu à travers toute
la france qui dure est parfois plus de
deux heures et au cours desquelles j'ai
eu à exposer le programme complet de mes
idées il est inadmissible que des
sondages d'opinion puissent être
publiées alors qu'une campagne
présidentielle est déjà ouverte
orientant d'une manière tout à fait
partial le jugement est peut-être même
la décision
des électeurs il y a là un certain
nombre d'abus un certain nombre de
dérèglements qui alourdissent
l'atmosphère de la campagne
présidentielle alors même que dans l'
équilibre dans le respect de nos
libertés dans le respect de la
personnalité de chaque candidat les
vrais problèmes de la france soit posée
au fond devant notre peuple
quel est le problème fondamental en
réalité deux possibilités s'offrent dab
ou bien aller dans le sens où le socialo
communisme vous invite
c'est à dire en voyant progressivement
disparaître la propriété privée des
moyens de production et de distribution
atelier petites et moyennes usine
propriété familiale agricole de voir
progressivement la culture pour chacun
disparaître devant la culture pour tous
de voir la police devenir un des organes
essentiels de l'état
et finalement en combinant la puissance
économique que le seul et à mettre de la
production et de la distribution ça
engendrait avait la puissance politique
faire déboucher notre pays qui s'est
tant battu dans son histoire pour
assumer ses équilibres et ses libertés
dans un véritable régime totalitaire il
aussi une deuxième solution raisonnable
bien français qui consiste à prolonger
l'oeuvre de la république en
l'améliorant dans le cas d'un ensemble
libéral mais juste et qui tentent de
rétablir ou de consolider un certain
nombre d' équilibre économique sociaux
humains spirituels et moraux
en fait la république a beaucoup fait
mais au cours de ces quinze années à un
certain nombre d' usure un certain
nombre de pesanteurs excessives sont à
observer et à combattre dans le cadre du
fonctionnement de l'état d
administration trop centralisée est trop
lourde
alors que le pouvoir politique entre
l'état central nos communes nos villes
et nos départements devraient être
distribués une certaine confusion entre
le domaine des affaires et le domaine de
la politique
d'autre part une absence d'arbitrage
efficace entre les petits les moyens
producteurs et distributeurs et les
puissantes sociétés nationales ou
multinationales dans le cadre de leur
accès au crédit
dans le cadre de leur accès à la
puissance économie enfin le contrôle
parlementaire de l'engagement des fonds
publics n'est pas encore suffisamment
assurée quant à la loi privé parfois
deux décrets et d'arrêtés correspondants
ou bien obtenant ces décrets et s'est
arrêté mais beaucoup trop tard il faut
la simplifier la faire connaître et
comprendre par notre peuple de manière à
alimenter la véritable démocratie
française
il y a là une recherche concrète
volontaire de réformes nouvelles
permettant à la république d'élargir ses
bases populaires et d'approfondir sa
légitimité vis-à-vis de notre peuple
en fait
est ce que le rôle du président de la
république peut être modifiée dans le
sens de cette recherche du progrès
politiques
j'affirme qu'il est possible de le faire
qu'il soit d'abord un arbitre ensuite un
animateur à la condition des
parfaitement indépendant de tous les
partis et de tous les groupes d'intérêt
notamment des intérêts financiers
j'affirme que la candidature que j'ai
proposé à notre pays est une candidature
digne d'accomplir cette mission
en effet tant dans mes mandats
parlementaires que municipales de mai
ministériel j'ai toujours essayé
d'appliquer un style politique nouveau
fait de mobilité de volonté d'efficacité
et celui qui vous parle peut affirmer la
cohérence entre ce qu'ils recommandent
dans le style politique nouveau de la
république et ce cas verse à travers ses
expériences
politique il a pu réaliser lui même et
si demain après une élection et au
moment de former mon gouvernement est de
faire en sorte que ce dernier présente à
l'assemblée nationale une plate forme de
programme politique
je devais prendre toutes mes
responsabilités je pourrais en raison
même du respect que ma porte est le
parlement en raison même aussi de
l'esprit d'ouverture qui serait le mien
je pense que mon action politique
pourrait être parfaitement
on brise et appuyer en réalité je ne
suis pas un homme seul de tous les coins
de france
afflux actuellement des encouragements
et des encouragements touchant parfois
vigoureux
de plus je ne suis pas seul parce que
plus de 150 groupes à travers la france
des comités de soutien en particulier se
sont constitués pour appuyer ma
candidature je la maintiens je poursuis
la lutte et je ne céderait pas aux
pressions aux entraves aux menaces d'où
elle vient m'appuyant profondément sur
l'expérience est sûre de sincère
conviction
est ce à dire qu'un homme seul entouré
de la sympathie de groupe et s'ouvrant
sur un besoin fondamental de
renouvellement dans
ce pays ne doivent pas faire appel aux
forces vives de ce dernier en fait qu'il
me soit permis de faire d'abord appel à
la jeunesse dont la mentalité profonde
est restée saine et qui n'a rien à voir
avec les organisateurs grotesque des
chahuts qui tente à violer la liberté de
réunion à la jeunesse française
je voudrais que l'on apporte plutôt le
sens des responsabilités et tout d'abord
la plus belle d'entre elles c'est à dire
celle de se situer dans la société
professionnelle et de choisir et d'aimer
un métier ou une profession
quand on lutte pour faire porter sa
marque dans le cadre du travail
on devient vis-à-vis de soi-même et
vis-à-vis des autres un vrai responsable
lui proposer à notre jeunesse de prendre
ses responsabilités corporels en
équilibre avec un idéal spirituel et
l'entraîné vers les stades vers
l'infirmation d'aylmer vers le
rapprochement avec la nature et enfin
grâce à la transmission des valeurs qui
nous ont fait ce que nous sommes
lui permettre d'accéder à un véritable
idéal de vie qui commence par la
protection de la vie je voudrais aussi
m'adresser aux épouses aux mères de
famille aux jeunes filles pour leur dire
à quel point elles sont l'âme de nos
familles en raison de leur tendresse de
leur passion en raison aussi de la
délicatesse de leur intuition qui les
bouches
à comprendre l'homme dont elle se sont
faits les compagnes
en fait dans les conditions de travail à
mi temps dans les usines dans les
ateliers dans les bureaux par une
meilleure répartition des allocations
familiales entre familles aisées et
familles plus modestes par un système
d'impôt sur le revenu qui encourage le
développement en nombre de la famille
je pense que nos époux et nos mères
pourraient être encouragées à accomplir
la totalité de leur rôle dans ce domaine
la famille cellule de base du pays étant
le cadre absolument irremplaçables pour
accueillir l'enfant lui permettent
d'acquérir son premier langage
d'accomplir ses premiers gestes envers
l'adulte et de former ainsi sa
sensibilité et son caractère
et si ces forces vives de la jeunesse de
nos familles françaises pouvaient
recevoir le message que de tout coeur
j'essai de leur transmettent alors
quelle belle tâche nous pourrions
accomplir pour la france en conclusion
je ne renonce pas jacques century au
contraire est dans la légalité et dans
le respect des eaux
la lutte que j'ai engagé pour ce pays et
pour son équilibre politique je vais
mobiliser davantage encore tout ce qui
m'a puis je vais changer la nature et le
style de mes réunions pour éviter tout
affrontement
et pour éviter tout désordre et je vous
demande
à vous qui m'écoutent et et qui écoute
et un homme propre un homme qui est
honnête et un homme qui aime ce qu'il
fait de vous mobiliser de dire à ceux
qui vous entourent de médée afin que
dans notre pays règne l'equilibre la
paix l'efficacité de tous nos efforts
vive la république et vive la prendre